sherrilyn grove today racking up a good
score against a i'm Shanklin despite the
fact that sam but actually studied this
game for an entire day exactly with max
ambassador grover mvl as he is lovingly
known Maxime that match had been a
really tight match surround the last
couple of days Sam is maybe in some
cases I'll played you a couple of rapid
games
what settled in today I think today I
just enjoyed the position on the first
day I did enjoy the position as well on
the second day I and I felt like I
really didn't quite grasp everything and
what obviously was playing quite badly
but today I really enjoyed playing this
position especially in the last minute I
saw this idea of going first c4 and
after the fact and so history and what
is just much better already so so yeah I
mean we had a couple of very interesting
games especially the first one where
everything was you know there was a huge
fight for the Queen side I mean I kind
of fun it but at the end I managed to to
defend and all those pieces your black
piece is hovering near his King and him
sacrificing in exchange I was completely
crazy that first game yeah and then I
yeah I just enjoyed playing this
position today and it showed in my
playing how are you feeling about 960
itself now that you played so many games
with 12 games various positions as well
versus standard chess it is very
interesting or so which try to actually
such problems from the start because we
have some time before the game start and
it gives some
gives us some very interesting insights
even though of course when we look at
the computer at the end of the day is
not so up here but ok but in general it
feels like everyone is was taking the
positions very seriously and actually
checking trick checking them as deeply
as we can with the amount of time we
have do you feel that Gary was saying
he's getting patterns the players are
starting to get patterns that even if
the position is randomized that there
may be some things positional ideas and
tactical ideas you start to get from the
various setups that maybe you can use in
other setups
yes exactly basically the idea is we
start to realize where our pieces should
be and you know sometimes of course
various ideas I mean here there was a
tactical motif with the whole country a
tent an item h8 and yeah we we just try
to not to blunder anything and I think
we manage Morris I mean of course I did
run a couple of sync
since Oreo in the match but yet today it
really felt like I was playing quite
well and we need putting the pressure
one thing that is difficult is of course
when we go back to chess mode and then
you know we we're kind of still in 916
mode and we're not sure what to do it's
already just chess that's kind of funny
actually the adjustment whoa thank you
so much and good luck in your games
tomorrow
thank you thank you Maxie